mais d'abord le président de la
république face à un nouveau tournant
dans cette crise sanitaire qui n'en
finit pas que peut-il annoncer demain
soir quelques pistes avec gaspard
flamand alors qu'il vient d'être
prolongé jusqu'à la fin du mois de
juillet le pass sanitaires pourraient
aussi être conditionnée à une troisième
dose de vaccin pour les plus de 65 ans
emmanuel macron pour l annoncer demain
soir pour inciter les personnes les plus
fragiles à prendre rendez vous on passe
sanitaire atteste du fait que vous êtes
protégés contre la copie dès que votre
vaccin est actif si au bout d'un certain
temps le vaccin n'est plus actif et
qu'il faut une dose de rappel il y à une
certaine logique plier aux passionnés
terre il faut impérativement que notre
pass sanitaires restent efficaces
actuellement la troisième dose de vaccin
anti covit 19 concernent les personnes
de plus de 65 ans celles atteintes de
maladies graves ou encore les résidents
en ehpad et le personnel soignant le
président du sénat qui avait fustigé la
prolongation du pass sanitaire ne voit
pas d'un bon oeil cette nouvelle mesure
là aussi c'est un débat sur les libertés
l'a conditionnée au poste sanitaire
c'est une entame de plus aux libertés ça
mérite un débat et ça mérite à vote donc
vous considérez que c'est une atteinte
bien sûr j'ai qu'une hauteur pour ce
médecin et sénateurs le pass sanitaire
n'est pas une solution miracle
selon lui cela vaccination obligatoire
peut permettre de protéger la population
le gouvernement nous a dit nous allons
poursuivre la politique d'aller vers et
nous allons les vaccinés puis compter
sur le fait que les tests étaient rendus
payants dans un certain nombre de cas
pour que les gens aillent se vacciner
or ça n'a pas fonctionné trois semaines
après le nombre de primo vaccination n'a
jamais été aussi bas il a continué à
baisser emmanuel macron s'exprimera
mardi soir des précisions devraient être
apportées sur cette question
et on en débat dès ce soir sur public
sénat avec mes invités françois patriat
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes sénateur de
la côte-d'or président du groupe le
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant sénat
membre du bureau exécutif de la
république en marche rené paul savary
bonsoir bien vous aussi vous êtes
sénateur l air les républicains de la
marne vous êtes médecin de formation
rachida inavoués rosé bonsoir bienvenue
médecin rhumatologue vous avez fondé en
mars 2020 à paris un centre médical
entièrement dédié aux comics 19 c'est un
des tout premiers si je me souviens bien
avec nous en visioconférence serge lama
qui est professeur de droit public à
l'université grenoble alpes bonsoir
serge slama bienvenue à vous aussi et
matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique heureux de vous retrouver
mathieu bonjour bienvenue de nouveau sur
le plateau de cette émission sens public
avec une question assez générale juste
avant on va dire 24 26 heures avant
l'allocution du président de la
république dans ses rangs vraiment se
consacrer sur la lutte la stratégie de
lutte contre contre l'épidémie qu'est ce
que vous attendez les uns et les autres
du président de la république demain je
commence avec me françois patriat
sur la je crois j'espère que le chef de
l'état je pense le chef de l'état va
poursuivre ce qui la monusco
d'aujourd'hui est à dire un dispositif
adapté en fonction des évolutions de la
maladie on l'a montré depuis le début
souvenez-vous sigean pudiquement
l'exemple de la vaccination qui a été
critiqué au début personne ne voulait
faire vacciner après il n'y a pas de
vaccin sont blessés en vacciner ensuite
on qui passait me taire pour passer
l'étape je pense que la france
aujourd'hui il n'a pas à rougir de ce
qui a été conduit en la matière contre
la copie 19 on a montré et la france
n'est pas mal placé aujourd'hui en
termes de vaccination sont mieux si je
prends les pays autour de chez nous il
ya aujourd'hui dix mille dix mille
nouveaux cas par jour il y en a plus de
35000 48 en allemagne ce jour
aujourd'hui en angleterre la situation
se dégrade aussi donc ce que j'espère
c'est que le chef de l'état poursuivre
cette stratégie graduée contre le
phénomène
et vous allez paul savary est ce que est
ce que vous pensez effectué selon une
certaine façon vous donner un satisfecit
aux exécutifs au présent république à
son gouvernement depuis allez je vais
dire depuis six mois peut-être pas avant
il faut prendre sur l'ensemble de la
gestion de milan de l'écrit on peut pas
donner un satisfecit quant il ya cent
mille morts voilà c'est que il ya un
nombre de morts qui place la france
mal placé dans l'échelle des pays quand
qui ont connu cette triste épidémie en
conséquence je donnerai pas de
satisfecit
maintenant quand y avait pas de vaccin
j'étais de ceux qui réclamaient les
vaccins alors quand y'a des vaccins je
vais être ceux qui finissent faut
utiliser avec ça et comme médecins on a
habitué à avoir des rappels donc je
pensais troisième dos a fait un rappel
c'est tout à fait légitime quel que soit
le type de vaccin que au bout d'un
certain temps et faye relancer le
système immunitaire on arrive à ce
moment là ce serait pas des efforts qui
ont produit toutes leurs conséquences si
nous ne faisons pas cette troisième dose
puisque par la gale s'atténuerait ne
baissons pas la garde et soyons
vigilants c'est la raison pour laquelle
je pense que effectivement quand il
faudra prendre cette décision de
l'inscrire au pas sur le poste sanitaire
je pense qu'il faut peser bénéfice
risque est que effectivement il ya un
risque d'atteintes aux libertés on va en
penser qu ancien bénéfices en
contrepartie un bénéfice sanitaire est
pour moi le bénéfice sanitaire est plus
important que le risque d'atteintes aux
libertés rachida et nina oui rose et on
vous parliez de l'allemagne
effectivement sur les sept derniers
jours 200 cas pour 100000 habitants ça
c'est le taux d'incidence qui est en
allemagne le pire depuis le 70 ans
laquelle sont deux vidéos et à 60 en
france est-ce que vous depuis votre
poste d'observation de médecins ce que
vous diriez que la situation est grave
et bénéficier nécessite un tour de vis
supplémentaire ou au contraire qu'on est
finalement dans une une bonne période 1
je mets des guillemets à tout ça pour ce
qui concerne la france malheureusement
on peut pas analyser le cas de la france
sans tenir compte du reste de l'europe
et du monde parce que c'est une pandémie
et que les frontières sont ouvertes et
qu'elles resteront ouvertes cette fois
ci parce qu'on n'est envisage pas de
lait il faut pas envisager de les fermer
pour ce qui est du cas de la france on
est au début de la cinquième épidémie
mais ce sera une épidémie qui ne sera
pas du tout de l'ampleur des autres
c'est à dire qu'elle sera pas de
l'ampleur en termes de décès et
d'hospitalisations gras moi je suis pas
du tout préoccupé cette fois ci comme
j'ai pu l'être extrêmement on a partagé
quelques plateaux l'an dernier vous
étiez souvent traversé quand vous et
quand vous parlez d'une gestion plus ou
moins satisfaisante par le gouvernement
je dirais sur la fin c'est à dire cette
année mais ça ne l'a pas du tout été en
2020 au contraire on a hurlé crier tous
les manquements à commencer par le
masque et on va mais on n'est pas là
pour ça aujourd'hui la situation est
moins préoccupante bien qu'il ya une
reprise épidémique dont on n'arrive pas
pour l'instant en france à mesurer
l'ampleur si un regard sur les états
unis à une reprise et peeling importante
et dans les études qu'ils ont regardé
c'est que en termes de mortalité et
d'hospitalisation extrêmement grave et
ben c'était beaucoup moins important
c'était un ratio de 1 sur 6 6 fois moins
dont on espère que pour la france ça
sera la même chose maintenant ce qu'il
faut protéger c'est toujours les mêmes
sons et personnes âgées mais plus
particulièrement les très âgés qui ont
été vaccinées en janvier février mars et
je pense que la vaccination est en train
de reprendre pour ces personnes vous
avez les gens moins âgée qui entre 65 et
80 qui eux ont été vaccinées entre avril
et juin donc là pour l'instant ceux qui
ont été vaccinés en mai en juin ils ont
pas besoin d'être vaccinés tout de suite
c'est entre le sixième et septième mois
ceux qui ont été vaccinés en mai juin
c'est descendre et janvier donc ya pas à
s'exciter et
l'on sait que le taux d'anticorps baisse
et je peux même gelé même testé pour moi
parce que je voulais faire un test en
juillet jamais été vacciné ma deuxième
matinée sont en février en juillet
j'avais encore 3000 anticorps au mois
d'octobre j'avais besoin de faire un
bilan pour des raisons personnelles j'en
ai profité pour avoir une idée je suis à
300 donc clairement le taux d'anticorps
dans les études le disent entre le 6e et
le huitième mois d'accord après vous
garder quand même une immunité
cellulaire salir la mémoire de ce
contact c'est à dire que vous allez été
mis en contact directement avec une
particule du virus et ça ça nous protège
et ça ne me protège surtout des formes
très grave c'est intéressant c'est
michel chez les jeunes en effet beaucoup
plus âgés c'est moins parce qu'ils ont
une immunité qui est plus faible donc
même l'unité cellulaire et quelques
jeunes au troisième 12 depuis un mois
oui alors non mais c'est pour ça que
c'est une chose sur lesquels il faut se
focaliser c'est la troisième dose est
imaginaire m la question pour qui mais
on y reviendra le on alterne dans ce
débat de savoir qui a fait une
population qu'elle tranche de population
quelle tranche d'âge quelles populations
à risque ou pas etc je voudrais donner
la parole à serge lama une première fois
dans dans ce débat un point de vue de
deux juristes vous pointez le le risque
d'un état d'urgence permanent et là
aussi on se projette un peu sur le
l'allocution du président demain c'est
cette tonalité là que vous craignez de
voir se répéter
oui très clairement d'une part la loi de
vigilance elle maintient deux
d'urgence et vous savez qu'on est encore
en état d'urgence outre-mer et d'autres
par le passé internet 1 à ce moment
d'exception qui était censé en être
enfermé dans une parenthèse temporelle
pour sortir de la crise sanitaire et on
voit qu'ils s'installent dans la durée
qu'on n'est pas près de 102 le bazar des
comme a dit le glisse de la santé et
donc le volet rice dupas sanitaires il
est là le phénomène d'accoutumance et
malheureusement on est tombé dans le
piège le piège fait est annoncée au mois
de mai on a été nombreux à dire que le
risque serait l'installation à la durée
a été prolongée jusqu'au 15 novembre
qu'un s'étend du 15 novembre est
désormais 31 juillet donc je pense que
on va avoir durablement cet instrument
et qui avec un instrument de
reproduction des inégalités en fait le
pas sanitaires donc je pense qu'il faut
ne vont plus vite possible réduire son
périmètre vraiment le limitèrent un
périmètre très restreint dont il ya un
vrai risque d'épidémie françois patriat
je suis en fait les accords avec cette
semaine d'abord le pass and i ter la
france a été le premier à le mettre en
place premier pays contesté dans ce pays
depuis beaucoup de pays l'ont adoptée en
europe et outre-atlantique et ailleurs
adopté avec succès et avec des avec des
contraintes plus dur que les nôtres
c'est la première chose à vrai dire
comme tels parce que pas sanitaires et
contrairement à ce que j'entends tous
les jours la loi qui a été voté non pas
aussi en a mais à l'assemblée la semaine
dernière ne dis pas qu'on va mettre
parce sanitaire jusqu'au match juillet
elle dit le gouvernement s'il en est
besoin
rétablira le pass sanitaire après
l'avoir enlevée s'il y avait une tribu
et pourquoi après les élections je le
dis parce que j'ai tant que j'entends
sur ce sujet beaucoup de polémique
pourquoi parce qu'imaginez que nous
soyons en pleine campagne présidentielle
aller le 10 avril est ce que vous
trouvez qu'un débat au parlement au
parlement le 10 avril pas ça n'était en
pas sanitaires seraient en pleine
campagne électorale à albi jour des
élections est-ce que
le débat serait totalement dénaturée par
l'instant même où il se produirait voilà
là ils risquent pas d'être dénaturé ya
pas de débat non non non attendez mais
le parlement est là pour être attentif à
tout ça si on dit qu'il ya une atteinte
aux libertés à travers le pass sanitaire
que je me promenais fort important c'est
obligatoire liberté qu'elle je suis
liberté de se déplacer de présenter
quelque chose et c'est seulement parce
que non non c'est pas quand je vais sur
la route présent je vais rebondir
jeudi qu'il n'atteindra comme né à
ceinture de sécurité la nasa est
d'offrir comme une atteinte aux libertés
un dock et la stature et pourtant la
cervelle à lévis un bien entendu non
mais je veux dire mais c'est clair ça
dessus mais il n'empêche que ça mérite
débat et ça mérite que le parlement se
positionne c'est pour ça que le sénat
était tout à fait opposés à cette date
du 22 juillet c'est pour ça qu'on doit
avoir une une réponse adaptée en
fonction de l'évolution et de la
proportionnelle à la gravité de la
maladie c'est pour ça c'est de défense
il a peu apprécié on peut
se prononcer maintenant un débat un
débat en pleine période telle est la vie
ne s'arrête pas
attendez il ya quand même des des vies
en jeu il ya ya ya quand même un certain
nombre de dispositions qui peuvent être
des battures toute sérénité dont nous a
semblé je vais donner la parole à
mathieu poissant dans un instant mais je
vouvoyais réagir serge slama sur les
propos du sénateur patriat la france
premier pays à avoir mis en place le
pass sanitaires ce n'est absolument pas
le cas c'est israël le premier permet
pas center il ya des pays du nord de
l'europe qu'ils ont mis bien avant la
france pour que ça c'est une affirmation
est inexacte et par ailleurs en fait
bliss atteint sa porte atteinte aux
libertés ça a été dit très clairement
par le conseil constitionnel il ya de
nombreuses libertés liberté d'aller lire
droit au respect de la vie privée
liberté d'entreprendre par exemple qui
sont atteints alors qui paraisait qui
ont été justifiée aux yeux du conseil
fonctionnel parce que précisément
l'objectif est d'éviter la propagation
d'épidémies donc c'est là le risque
épidémique détermine la peau cité
d'utiliser ne pas s'intéresser pas du
tout à le lire la vaccination également
je sais bien qu'il utilisait comme ça et
donc vraiment
alors on a une petite coupure jours de
françois patriat mathieu évidemment
quand on est à aulas 24 un peu plus à 26
eur date d'une allocution présidentielle
là on se demande c'est quoi les les
ingrédients d'une un discours réussi
pour un présent la république il y en a
sept ou en tout cas cette erreur à ne
pas commettre la première chose c'est
qu'il faut avoir quelque chose à dire
séparez bête mais il faut quand il le
rappeler il ya 30 ans est un homme qui
s'appelait jacques billand que
conseiller successivement le président
mitterrand puis président chirac qui
avait théorisé la rareté de la parole
présidentielle à la fois pour qu'elle
ait plus d'impact et puis pour qu'elles
répondent surtout à une attente dans
l'opinion alors ce premier point c'est
raté parce que la rareté de la parole
présidentielle c'est quand même la 9e
allocution depuis le début de cette
crise qu vide et puis par ailleurs
emmanuel macron parle beaucoup depuis la
rentrée sur beaucoup de sujets donc pour
la rareté on n'y est pas pour ce qui est
en revanche de faire monter la tente la
stratégie du désir d avec kiel en là
pour le coup on n'y est pas ce qu on
annonçant dès la semaine dernière a
quitté l ai parlé on voit bien qu'il ya
eu une chute dans l'opinion en tout cas
une attente le président a créé quelque
chose
être deuxième deuxième clé c'est avoir
une parole suivi les faits alors
linguiste il parle de discours
performatif c'est quand on dit on fait
l'exemple c'est la question du 12
juillet dernier vous souvenez il dit
qu'il va mettre en place le plus le pass
annie terre pour le coup ça booste
vaccination de façon quasi automatique
là la seule annonce de son allocution à
me fais reprendre des rendez vous sur dr
libre mais pour avoir une période
performative comme on dit il faut que le
message soit clair et pas fourre-tout au
risque d'ajouter de la confusion au
caire si on commence demain à rappeler
les gestes barrière pu avoir un message
très clair puis après à faire un tour
d'horizon de réformes en cours de parler
des retraites ça risque d'être beaucoup
plus confus la troisième clé c'est qu'il
faut une exigence de sincérité alors ça
à quelqu'un qui savait bien faire ça
c'est edouard philippe il a rivalisé
bessat je ne sais pas il ya de nouvelles
courage de reconnaître que dans l'état
actuel de l'économie ce qu'on avait à
l'époque sur le vide ils ne savaient pas
équivalent macro on a eu plus de mal à
l'entendre il a fallu attendre
le 28 octobre dernier c'est celui de
2020 pour l'entendre dire avant nous
tout bien fait non un début de mea culpa
qui donne qui donne une exigence
sincérité et même ce printemps il a
fallu attendre pour qu'ils disent est ce
que je peux vous dire les yeux dans les
yeux qu'on ne sera plus jamais débordé
us par ce virus c'est impossible donc là
on le voit il faut cette exigence de
sincérité la quatrième attention aux
phrases définitives vous venez à
quelques traits affolant très alarmiste
par exemple fameux nous sommes en guerre
et qui était prononcé quatre jours après
une précédente allocution où il avait
maintenu le 1er tour des municipales
s'étaient pas cohérent mais les phrases
définitives a peut être aussi optimiste
vous soyez de retour des jours heureux
où d'autres anti par des de l'épidémie
au passé le 14 juillet 2020 mais ça
c'est ça c'est dangereux 5e clé éviter
le catalogue il faut fixer un cap et
s'ensuit ils sont se tenir au bon vieux
principe l'intendance suivra en gros en
gros c'est pas au président de la
république d'annoncer comme il l'avait
fait vous souvenez il ya un an qui il
est essentiel qui n'est pas essentiel la
réouverture des disquaires tout ça c'est
plutôt du niveau du premier ministre
voire des ministres enfin 6e clés ne pas
se mettre tout seul dans la seringue
c'est à dire attention aux échéances
qu'on donne souvient que en octobre 2020
il avait annoncé qu'il parle aux
français un mois plus tard un mois plus
tard ils n'avaient pas grand chose à
dire sinon des dates qui n'ont pas été
tenus ils avaient annoncé par exemple
que le 20 janvier on ouvrirait les
restaurants les salles de sport qu'elle
serait pas été possible avec l'arrivée
des nouveaux variants puis enfin la
dernière clé c'est s'assurer du service
après vente quand on décide tout seul
que rien ne filtrait bain les gens sont
pas forcément au courant ils ont du mal
à faire le service après vente et on a
parfois j'allais dire souvent entendu
des ministres le lendemain d'une
allocution présidentielle raconter un
peu tout et son contraire parce que tout
n'avait pas été calé ou pourra reprendre
la mission qui a été suivie ou ou pas
vous faisiez référence à l'effet de
simplement de l'annnonce de l'allocution
présidentielle effectivement 65000
rendez-vous qui ont été pris vendredi
c'était plus 61% par rapport à la
semaine précédente sur susurre d'octo
lips et seront on peut espérer un
un effet un effet vaccination le même
effet
docteur inouïe aux essais savez
étonnamment bien fonctionné au moins de
juillet oui complètement parce que la
gabelle oublier son ex avait beaucoup
fonctionné pour les jeunes parce qu'il
se retrouvait en situation de difficulté
pouvaient pas prendre l'avion il pouvait
pas aller au restaurant pouvait pas
prendre un verre pour les strates donc
ils sont retrouvés coincés ça les a
quand même bien motivés c'était presque
un coup de poker
peut-être que ça va recommencer mais ma
chez des patients qui me disent mais la
troisième douce et elle est obligatoire
mais cela fait sens que c'est pas
obligatoire je ne la fait pas du courant
dont la troisième dose obligatoires
alors on pourrait toujours en cours
uniquement les gens alors c'est ça qui
alors pour les plus de 65 ans pour les
raisons qu'on a déjà discuté en début
d'émission avec cette paire d'immunité
et notamment avec les anticorps qui
baissent mais chez tout le monde mais en
plus une immunité cellulaire qui est
plus faible on est à 43 % de plus de
seins de 65 ans vaccinée avec la
troisième dose selon celle ci c'est très
bien parce que je vous ai dit en a qui
ont été vaccinés comme me joins donc le
on peut pas des vaccinés avant décembre
janvier donc et donnons le temps et puis
ça il a été décidé que finalement
maintenant tout ne se ferait pas dans
les centres de vaccination et c'est chez
le médecin chez le pharmacien donc ça
c'est très bien parce que du coup il va
y avoir de la pédagogie des explications
voire aussi l'enjeu de la grippe qui va
arriver deux 2 que les gens soient prêts
ils soient vaccinés parce que on craint
plus une saturation avec ces épidémies
qu'on n'a pas eu les autres années que
réellement par là par l'aco vide à
nouveau et les autres personnes qui
doivent être absolument vacciner et le
son en fait ce sont tous les gens
immunodéprimés les greffés l'organe les
maladies hématologiques grave les
leucémies lymphomes et caetera et les
gens qui sont sous chimiothérapie les
traitements into ce qui baisse limitée
et je peux vous dire que cela le sont
parce que leurs médecins spécialistes
leur a dit de le faire ils en sont déjà
la quatrième dose et ils ont fait leur
troisième dose cet été et ils ont déjà
fait la quatrième d'autres et il se
trouve que chez certaines personnes très
immunodéprimés j'ai le cas d'une
patiente qui a été greffée rénale et
elle me dit je suis déjà la quatrième
régime quatrième dose et à midi
effectivement première deuxième dose pas
d'anticorps troisième dose stream 2e et
4e 12 enfin la des antiques temps parce
qu'ils ont un système hiide certainement
donc ces gens là globalement normalement
devrait être son dans un dans un circuit
médical t'en parle de 5 millions de deux
personnes à convaincre encore parce que
vous savez vous qui on intègre dans sa
lettre dans cette catégorie des
personnes fragiles âgées parler des
pluies plus fragiles ceux là sont
motivés leur médecin et sont dans un
sujet donc
facebook vous en avez d'autres c'est
ceux qui sont en haut mise en situation
d'obésité de diabète de fragilité pluri
pathologique et cela on a plus de temps
plus de mal à les atteindre mais plutôt
en sueur patriat ça veut dire qu'il ya
eu un des trous dans la raquette en
termes de communication de prévention le
message est passé auprès de ces
populations c'est peut-être aussi ça
l'un des enjeux de l'allocution de
demain non il dort beaucoup de personne
ne pensait que il avait deux vaccins
qu'ils étaient immunisés on leur a dit
le vaccin c'est la panacée c'est qu'ils
ne pensaient pas systématiquement une
troisième il y pense pour la grippe
naturellement moi-même j'ai ma troisième
dose de vaccin au vaccin grippe qui est
fait aujourd'hui ce que j'y pense
naturellement parce que c'est me
protéger je reprends un instant votre
intervenant après j'ai pas dit du monde
c'est vrai tout à l'heure et dix
premiers pays en europe des pays
d'europe de l'europe des 28 aujourd'hui
la france en est le premier il c'est les
autres qui l'ont mis seconde herman
j'entends bien les libertés c'est quoi
la liberté est ce que la liberté c'est
de pouvoir montrer qu'on est vaccinée
pour se protéger et protéger les autres
où est la liberté c'est d'être malade
alors qu'on est con ne qu'on sait qu'on
est à risque c'est d'aller à l'hôpital
c'est de mourir éventuellement ses de
causer des douleurs familiale et de
coûter coûté 1 argent terrible aux
contribuables parce que les gens qui
veulent pas faire vacciner au nom de la
liberté aujourd'hui et qui se retrouve
aujourd'hui en réanimation quinze jours
trois semaines combien ça coûte docteur
trois jours les relations quoi ça coûte
aux poteries bloque donc nous devons
nous qui les hommes responsables ce
coup-là 3 ayez pour des gens qui disent
mon nom de la liberté bah tant pis pour
moi ça fait rien résolu comme ça
on soigne pas le cancer
qui a pas de mai notamment de prévention
contre ce qui alors que là ils peuvent
se prémunir non
j'entends bien j'entends bien pour avoir
ce débat aussi sur la chasse aux jeunes
lieu avant-hier en même temps en temps
mais non mais cette dame est pareil dans
des trous dans la raquette nous est tout
à leur insu croissant nous dit la parole
est trop abondante écouter on est dans
une épidémie qui rené paul savary l'a
rappelé a fait 120 mille morts en france
pas plus que dans les autres pays en
tout cas moi comme à cannes angleterre -
pause états unis noah compose du brésil
- dans beaucoup de pays non mais
qu'importe je reviens pas d'essayer pas
eu de locutions pour rendre en attendait
mais aussi si si alors donc dans une
épidémie comme tel le président il parle
le 12 juillet qu'est-ce qui fait le 12
juillet mais fait tout il parle bon des
vaccinations donc sa parole n'a pas été
inutile libre et nettoie elle a été
utile à ce que les gens se fassent
vacciner les clients
utilisent aujourd'hui mettre le curseur
de cette troisième dose qu'elle va dire
ne sait pas très bien ce que je connais
votre votre mission sentiment c'est de
dire on voit bien qu'on est en début
d'une nouvelle épidémie qui sera dr
nadia l'instant moins grave que les
suivantes mais qui néanmoins va encore
prise quant à nouveau d'entravé nos
libertés vraiment vraiment nos libertés
si jamais on est le même donc dit
aujourd'hui attention pour vous les plus
de 65 ans pour tous ceux qui ont des
comorbidités attention vous risquez non
seulement d'avoir des formes peut-être
moins graves mais certains des formes
graves quand même mais de surcroît les
autres vais mourir aussi donc de
rappeler simplement c'est qu'il a dérapé
le 12 juillet il serait préférable
compte tenu de ce qu'il imaginait qu on
ait pas de vaccin aujourd'hui mais
imaginez qu est-ce qu on entendra le
pays la france a tout raté il n'y a pas
de vaccin on va les attendre
journalistes qu'il en faudra cinq ans
pour maxime etc on a les vaccins on a
les moyens donc la parole du président
demain sur ce sujet me paraît nécessaire
pour relancer une voiture alors juste
dans un instant jour est qu on écoute le
le ministre de la santé un instant
c'était le 26 octobre dernier ils
étaient auditionnés ici même au sénat
faut-il conditionner le pass sanitaires
à la troisième dose de vaccin n'écarte
pas cette hypothèse écouter s'il y avait
une orientation des autorités pour que
nous intégrions la troisième dose dans
le pass sanitaires alors ça poserait
effectivement des questions techniques
assez fragile assez sensible mais que
quand je dis ça ça veut pas dire on peut
pas le faire mais c'est la question que
vous posez qui est technique mais plus
de 65 ans le pass le reconnaît les gens
qui ont des comorbidités qui n'ont pas
65 ans aujourd'hui le pasteur que ne le
reconnaît pas donc ça doit faire l'objet
de discussions à la voie au niveau
technique et médical pour identifier les
voies et moyens pour permettre de nous
assurer la protection et parle par la
troisième dose par les deux rappels des
gens qui sont dans la catégorie des
moins de 65 ans qui sont appelés à avoir
un rappel
rené paul savary le pass sanitaire c'est
c'est presque c'est devenu un levier de
vaccination en fait mais tout à fait
mais c'est bien l'ambiguïté du discours
macro nist un dut en même temps quoi on
veut pas dire que la vaccination
obligatoire mais on prend des mesures
telle qu'elle est rendue sicaud
logiquement obligatoire on tord le bras
aux gens quoi plutôt que leur dire
écoutez on franchit pas voilà il faut
laisser indispensable à la vaccination
on peut s'y pointe comme on veut c'est
indispensable on c'est vrai qu'il ya
d'autres pays qui n'ont même pas le
premier vaccin font quand même pas
l'oublier donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle nos concitoyens doit quand même
sauté de joie de pouvoir bénéficier
quand même de cette vaccination qu'on
voit bien sauve des vies 1 s'impose à
moi j'ai eu un petit ils sont comme ça
dans une commune ou pas de pot il ya
quelqu'un du conseil municipal quel mal
réagi aux vaccins du coup personne
personne c'est vacciner et finalement il
y en a eu qui ont eu des complications
bien sûr il ya eu 1 kloster et puis une
complication des maladies qu'on fait que
les effets auraient été beaucoup plus
grave pour ceux qui ont été touchés que
les et les complications de la haye de
la vaccination donc c'est vrai que tous
ces exemples ou à vous montrer quelque
part que c'est indispensable de se
vacciner
alors maintenant maintenant que va dire
le président macro il y en a deux un
pays où on attend la parole du messie
coin c'est quand même est extraordinaire
la fascination de la parole
présidentielle pour dire quoi bas et que
la réalité de la vie c'est celle là
voilà demain on va nous dire en prendre
la parole pour dire ce que l'on met la
ceinture de sécurité
république que soit la couleur politique
du président ouais m'enfin ça a pris des
dimensions quand même qu'ils sont assez
époustouflante moi qui connaît déjà
depuis plus de 40 ans la vie politique
l'ayant suivi quand même un bon je vois
que ça prend ça prend quelque chose qui
m'est qui marchent semble-t-il puisque
les français réagissent donc tant mieux
mais ils peuvent aussi réagir
différemment on va poser et continuent
de poser la question des libertés
publiques avec serge slama et peut-être
d'une forme de jeu c'est pas de dérive
de l'exercice du pouvoir est ce que vous
aller jusque là
oui ça y est clairement loris alors
juste un petit rectificatif le premier
pays européen à avoir instauré le corps
en a passé le danemark en europe le vrai
risque de l'état d'urgence parce
qu'encore une fois cette fois on est
prolongé la possibilité de recourir à
l'état de relance d'urgence ou l'état
d'urgence dans ce territoire français et
puis le deuxième en le pass sanitaire
qui voilà qui s'installe dans la durée
le joueur a très bien à quel moment on
cessera de l'utiliser puisque on rentre
dans la cinquième vague et comme on
comprend la logique la troisième dose le
pasteur sera conditionnée à la troisième
dose est donc le temps de vacciner les
français puisque on commence avec les
personnes de 65 ans et les personnes
vulnérables qui ont ensuite on aura une
extension eh bien on voit bien que on va
exiger le passé des terres durablement
jusqu'au et ensuite on peut craindre
deux vagues dans le futur puisque tous
les français seront pas vaccinés donc la
solution elle est connue elle est
relative d'ailleurs la solution c'est
l'obligation vaccinale en tout cas la
l'extension l'obligation vaccinale et
assumer cette obligation vaccinale
malheureusement le mcpl prison public
n'a jamais assumé l'a jamais a lancé et
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui s'il y avait
une mesure annoncée c'est dire on va
envisager pour certaines catégories de
la population d'une obligation vaccinale
je pense notamment aux policiers par
exemple qui pourrait soulager les jambes
des gendarmes alors françois patriat ça
vous fait rire c'est peut-être ce qui
sera annoncée de nan est quand même le
nord conditionnement de gfic je vais
satisfaire à la troisième dose pour
certaines catégories impasse je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas ce que dira le
président mais je serais presque plus je
souhaite je souhaite qu'il soit plus
incitatif et coercitif
les mesures coercitives obligations
sacré de la rébellion sacré de la
défiance je ne vois pas aujourd'hui
demain aller chercher des personnes
âgées avec des gendarmes pour le dire
vous allez vous vacciner de force ça
n'est pas possible on le sait très bien
la vaccination obligatoire n'est pas
possible donc essayons de faire ce que
fait le président d'avoir une parole
quatre mois après une autre dans une
crise comme cela ça me paraît pas trop
rapprochées et dernière chose j'entends
bien ce qu'on dit sur laquelle
aujourd'hui est ce que vous pensez
d'abord les jours heureux tout à l'heure
bon est ce que quand le président est
dans une crise dont personne ne connaît
exactement tous les ressorts aujourd'hui
qui ne s'est pas trompé parmi les parmi
les médecins qui ne s'est pas trompé ou
a dit des choses parmi tous les corps
médical attention frère jumeau d'yves
deudon mais c'est le rôle du président
donald l'espoir aux français par de
l'espoir vain on a tous espéré de
l'année dernière après la première vague
on allait retrouver des jours où
devaient se pouvait se libérer et au
bout du compte moi quand j'interroge les
gens j'ai connu une époque je vais sur
le terrain toutes les semaines je vois
des gens tous les jours quand
j'interroge les français parmi les
choses qui donnent comme positive au
chef de l'état il a plutôt bien géré la
crise c'est sage entendons territoire la
vaccination la crise la crise mais sur
la question de
de ceux de ceux de cet état d'urgence
permanent que dénonce serge slama qu'est
ce que vous répondez à ça est ce que
effectivement on n'est pas dans une dans
une dérive petit à petit est il du
fonctionnaire notre démocratie
faudrait-il au nom de liberté peut
priver donges temps par l'état chaque
jour parce qu'il ya une menace je n'ai
pas se répandre ses docteurs mais pense
j'espère qu'elles pensent comme moi
parce qu'elle menace de cinquième bague
août sixième vague faut-il relâcher la
pression faut-il relâcher la pression
faut-il laisser des gens non vaccinés
aller dans des lieux publics où ils
peuvent à nouveau comptable d'autres
gens moi je pense que non
c'est la prudence c'est la prudence si
la logique c'est même la sécurité pour
les français de dire d'écouter s'il ya
des menaces de résurgence le pass
habitat vers un mode de réponse mais le
problème actuellement c'est que la
majorité de la population est vaccinée
puisqu'elle 50 millions qui sont
vaccinées ce qu'on veut c'est on sait
que les gens vaccinés sont porteurs du
virus et certains me font même la forme
simple du coup vite voire grave c'est
pour ça que l'idée de de maintenir ce
pass sanitaires et le rendre au delà
d'une certaine période et presque un peu
ridicule parce qu on est actuellement
dans une situation non il ya des gestes
barrières manuelles et non non non non
je te disais rien ne sont plus maintenu
à cause du passé ni terme et assure être
dissociée bouillant
sanitaire
sanitaires
il ya des lieux de réunions publiques
moi je t'ai est regrets demande comme un
montre son pass sanitaire ensuite on se
sent un peu libéré mais
psychologiquement je me lâche mais moi
je suis allé au théâtre récemment et
j'ai présenté mon pass à l'inter je me
suis retrouvé à côté d'un couple qui
n'avait pas son mât donc j'ai poliment
n'imaginant pas que c'était leur droit
demandé s'il n'avait pas l'intention ils
m'ont dit on à le droit donc je suis je
me suis levé j'ai été voir la cep sony
on dit oui c'est comme ça le pass à nice
et discrétion
pourquoi parce que ces deux personnes
qui sont vaccinées peuvent être portés
en sus vous dit pas de pass à me taire
je dis que le passé assez récent
sans les alors vaut mieux les chefs de
barrières plutôt que de maintenir le
pass annie terre parce que de toute
façon maintenant 50 millions la
population est vaccinée donc on en a
c'est une fausse c'est une fausse
illusion de protection vaut mieux
remettre les gestes barrière qui ont
disparu vous n'avez plus de gel
hydroalcoolique nulle part et tous ces
endroits où il ya des rassemblements
importants je dis pas que pour aller
faire vos courses vous allez imposé ou
sur les marchés le masque et le génie
droite connu mais il ya énormément
d'endroits dix ans après va les
encourager les gens à ne pas faire
vacciner ceux qui ne veulent pas déjà
aujourd'hui on vous disait lui même
parce que vous avez dénoncé ce qu'ils
ceux qui veulent pas se permettre on est
de toute façon on n'y arrivera pas parmi
les dix millions l'extension en asie la
barrière on a bien compris je
je demande à marion vidéo de nous
rejoindre parce qu'il ya une autre
question qui est au centre de ce
thématique de cette thématique de
l'atteinte aux libertés c'est la levée
du secret médical dans les écoles louis
une mesure qui fait partie du projet de
loi à vizille ans sanitaire qui a été
adopté vendredi dernier à l'assemblée
nationale et qui permet donc désormais
aux chefs d'établissements des collèges
et des lycées d'avoir accès aux
résultats des tests pcr de leurs élèves
ou encore à leur statut vaccinal et pour
les opposants du texte parmi lesquels on
trouve évidemment les sénateurs ce
nouveau pouvoir confier au chef
d'établissement constituent une matière
une mesure liberticide et surtout pose
question en matière de levée du secret
médical je vous livre certaines des
réactions sénatoriales pour le centriste
loïc hervé on veut confier au chef
d'établissement un rôle qui n'est pas le
leur alors qu'eux mêmes ne sont pas
soumis à l'obligation vaccinale autre
position celle de philippe balle l'école
ne doit faire aucune distinction entre
élèves selon qu'ils soient vaccinés ou
pas car la vaccination n'est pas
obligatoire et les élèves n'ont pas à
faire les frais des décisions prises par
leurs parents et puis écouter encore le
président des groupes les républicains
du groupe l'est républicain au sénat
bruno retailleau
la marque du sénat c'est que nous soyons
gardien des libertés publiques c'est
aussi à ce titre que nous avons refusé
l'accès au statut virologique l'accès au
statut vaccinal pour les élèves
vis-à-vis notamment des directeurs
d'établissement de l'éducation nationale
nous pensons que les données de santé
sont de toutes les données celles qui
doivent faire l'objet d'un degré de
protection très élevé enfin je
terminerai avec la position des
sénateurs socialistes pour qui cette
nouvelle mesure est en fait une
obligation vaccinale qui ne dit pas son
nom alors quelle est la volonté du
gouvernement avec avec cette mesure
faciliter une progr un protocole
d'urgence oui car pour rappel depuis le
mois de septembre en cas de
contamination au collège ou dans les
lycées les parents doivent transmettre
une attestation sur l'honneur signée
affirmant que leurs enfants étaient
vaccinés ou avait un test pcr à négatif
mais pour gouvernement les résultats de
ne sont à ce jour pas satisfaisant d'où
cette nouvelle mesure est écoutée
d'ailleurs à ce sujet jean michel
blanquer le ministre de l'éducation il
était interrogé ce matin par nos
confrères de france info le système
avait élaboré à partir de la rentrée de
septembre on s'aperçoit que c'est
insuffisant que c'est aussi
enfin il ya des trous dans la raquette
pour le dire ainsi et donc c'était
beaucoup mieux d'avoir ce contrôle
vaccinant des trous dans la raquette se
dit inquiète des parents qui ne
répondait pas ou des parents qu'ils
mentaient sur le nas a pu arriver qu'il
ya des mensonges en effet donc c'est
quand même mieux de pouvoir se baser sur
ceux là qui n'est quand même pas une
dimension très très importante de de
l'état de santé de quelqu'un c'est à
dire face est important pour nous pour
notre sujet mais je dirais c'est pas une
violation d'un secret très très
important justement pour les sénateurs
au contraire c'est justement un secret
importants conséquence sur cette mesure
mais également sur l'ensemble des taxes
au vigeant sanitaires ils ont saisi le
conseil constitutionnel
merci marion pour tous toutes ces
explications rené paul savary pourquoi
cette saisine du conseil constitutionnel
justement m'a écouté c'est là
visiblement c'est une entorse à ce qui
s'est toujours fait le secret médical ne
veut pas dire que c'est au détriment de
la personne c'est au contraire pour
sauver des personnes et il est il et il
n'existe pas entre médecins il n'existe
pas avec les professions paramédicales
donc il ya des médecins scolaires qui
existe dans les établissements donc le
secret médical peut être
levée quand il ya un rapport de médecins
médecin simplement donc ce n'était pas
difficile dans les établissements de
mettre quelque chose sur pied qui
permettait de respecter justement cette
déontologie qui est essentiel pour
assurer la confiance des patients
fallait s'y prendre autrement mais dès
l'instant où la vaccination n'est pas
obligatoire vous pouvez pas et il est
très difficile de refuser un élève dans
l'air ça pose un certain nombre de
problèmes
d'assurance de responsabilité etc c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ce qui
apparaît à travers ce texte c'est la
raison pour laquelle je pense que la
position du sénat est très sage il faut
par le biais des médecins scolaires
trouvé la solution parce que il faut en
trouver une mais pas ce qui a été
proposé me semble-t-il qui est une vraie
atteinte là
lider terrain les
infirmières les infirmières scolaires ne
peut pas le fait de s'être et médicales
c'est quelque chose c'est la nounou à la
hollande où la vie de serge slama là
dessus on vous écoute je suis un peu
étonné la déclaration du ministre
rappelle il est professeur de droit
public donc il sait très bien que c'est
un secret importante secret médical le
conséquence elle a déjà garanti
d'ailleurs c'est le respect au
droit au respect de la vie privée qui
était protégé par la constitution et il
a déjà dit en la matière qui font
vigilance particulière lorsqu'il a une
transmission de données sensibles donc
il a dit d'ailleurs l'occasion de la loi
du 11 mai de 2020 vous savez la loi de
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire alors pour le coup dalle mais
tout même du raison du secret médical
elle est possible à elle met vraiment
très contrôlée auprès de personnes
habilitées à doit être nécessaires et
proportionnées donc l'enjeu ici sera de
savoir si l'accès par des personnels
habilités notamment des provisions est
assez encadrée pour pour passer de la
barre rationnelle voilà donc je peux pas
dire manière affirmé que ces
inconditionnels en charge des problèmes
de concilier françois patriat pourquoi
pourquoi au comment justifier cette
mesure ecoutez-moi jardin ans a regardé
ce débat avec un peu de recul je me dis
je mets pas en cause rené-paul savary
mais je remets en cause des grandes
déclarations sur mais sur liberticide ou
levée du secret médical je dirais qu'il
ya ceux qui font de la politique puis à
ce que saïd d'enrayer la maladie est de
faire en sorte qu en page 2 - avec les
enfants de l'école et garder à l'école
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui pour acheter
d'établissement de coquelles parce qu'un
enfant est positif et qu'il n'aurait pas
dit et qu'on venant là les enfants ne
sont pas vaccinés aujourd'hui c'est de
transmettre aujourd'hui est ce que
vraiment c'est liberticide je pense
qu'il faudrait qu'on revienne de la
vraie notion des valeurs si vous voulez
parler des privations de liberté je vous
en prie dans quelques pays vous allez
voir comment ça se passe en turquie en
russie en chinois en chine vous allez
voir parler de privation de liberté en
france et de dictature quand vous
entendu parler c'est me paraît à la fois
exagéré a promis de fermer ou non mais
pas ce soir je l'entendis hautement
liberticide mais parce que le secret
médical extrêmement important pour les
médecins et on sait comme le secret de
la confession c'est même chose c'est une
ligne rouge sur laquelle on ne peut pas
passer on ne doit pas passer égal et
quelques exceptions de savoir qu'un
enfant est positif c'est le secret
médical louis de savoir
oui non c'est secret médical c'est à
dire que là il ya une délégation de
tâches qui est en train de se faire en
dehors du milieu médical alors que ce
n'est pas justifiée on dit pas qu'il ne
faut pas en tenir compte on ne dit pas
qu'il ne faut pas intervenir mais c'est
pas aux chefs d'établissement
d'intervenir c'est une délégation de
tâches c'est à dire que comme on a une
pénurie de médecins mais je vais y
aurait deux soigneurs on essaie de
déléguer à d'autres personnes qui ne
sont pas habilités qui sont pas formés à
ça on n'est pas en train de dire qu'il
ne faut pas que les enfants qui sont
positifs restent chez eux on est à 30
juste de dire que ce n'est pas aux
établissements savez très bien docteur
18 le nombre de médecins dans
l'établissement alicia mille élèves
combien de médecins scolaires dedans
comment vous allez faire ce sens je sais
bien les affaires penser si la même
manière qu'on met en effet mais qui va
leur dire
on est dans l'impasse dans laquelle on
est depuis qu' à cette pénurie de
soignants parle depuis 10 20 ans dans le
pays on paye aujourd'hui cette pénurie
et donc qu'est ce qu'on fait on délègue
on délègue à des gens qui n'ont pas les
compétences on délègue à des gens qui ne
sont qui ne sont même pas de ce milieu
professionnel et qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer moi je me souviens de mes la
situation et celle là aujourd'hui mais
oui mais les filtres alliance est
aujourd'hui à verser les choses partie
commençait par engager des infirmières
des médecins pour savoir après si on
contrôle les
cas les médecins traitants et qui a des
infirmières etc à des pharmaciens et qui
se peut se régler de façon simple avec
le dossier médical partagé où vous avez
l'accord du patient d'attendre son
dossier médical comme quoi il est
vacciné madoff est d'accord pour qu'on
confie l'information
d'accord en vue en régime d'exception
c'est pas la dictature vincent ne parle
mais en régime d'exception ont fait des
entorses aux règles générales quand
l'exception devient la règle et c'est le
cas avec la pandémie qui aujourd'hui
s'est installé dans notre quotidien est
là pour durer donc on va devoir vivre
avec on peut plus vivre avec des mesures
d'exception il faut trouver de nouvelles
règles générales la règle générale
facile et simple c'est la vaccination
obligatoire pour l'instant parce que là
pour le coup c'est le cas pour les
élèves quand
vous êtes enfant vous devez vous laisser
les enfants
c'est pas mal de fautes de pouvoir avoir
une règle simple et générale qui serait
la vaccination obligatoire même si on
est un gendarme pour aller chercher les
gens quand vous dites aux gens c'est
obligatoire vous faut quand même parié
sur le fait que la plus grande partie
naissance et a constitué la de même
façon que la ceinture de sécurité est
obligatoire la plupart des gens là mais
si on avait une mesure simple comme ça
ça éviterait toutes ces espèces
d'enchevêtrement de règles et de
dérogation à la règle voilà pour les
geeks qui nous met dans cette situation
assez inextricables allait entamer en
même temps merci beaucoup merci à vous
pour participer à ce débat vous parliez
de la pénurie de médecins justement
c'est le thème de notre reportage les
électeurs ont la parole